madam chair it appears that you are the
one who is jeopardizing or the Fed is
the one who is jeopardizing this
investigation am I wrong the FOMC has in
place a clear set of rules for that are
to be followed when there are
allegations of a leak you didn't follow
them they call for a review of the
incident by the General Council and the
FOMC secretary we've described to you
how that reviewed took place did the
General Counsel per your guidelines talk
to the fmoc board or did he make a
recommendation to the IG because
requirement is that they may do initial
review and solely determine whether they
make a referral to the IG they didn't do
that right Oliver resident do that
before his review was complete he was
informed by the I jayden if the IG had
undertaken his own investigation and
therefore the IG was already looking at
it before it was necessary for him to
make a decision which I referred to the
I time is almost up I jointly sorry if
anyone is trying to sweep this under the
rug it's the Fed